صار للمتداولين في العملات المشفره
انتعاشه حقيقيه سجلت العملات المشفره
اليوم فاول مره منذ اكثر من شهرين استقر
سعر البيتكوين فوق مستوى 20,000$ وارتفعت
الحصه والسوقيه لاكبر عمله مشفره بحوالي
41% بلغت القيمه السوقيه للعملات المشفره
بشكل الاجمالي حوالي 976 مليار دولار
مقتربتا من اختراق حاجز التريليون دولار
هذه الزيادات في قيمه البيتكو ان رفعت
مستوى التداول على العملات المشفره بنسبه
80% خلال 24 ساعه الاخيره
فما هي اسباب هذا الارتفاع يقول موقع
كريبتو بوليتر المختص في العملات المشفره
ان هذا الارتفاع راجع بالاساس الى الجهود
التي بذلتها وزاره العدل الامريكيه والتي
ساهمت في القبض على سام بان براي مالك
شركه اف تي اكس للعملات المشفره المتهم
بالاحتيال كما ان اعلان الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب الامريكي يعني احداثي لجنه
الفرعيه خاصه للعملات المشفره اعادت ثقه
مجددا للمستثمرن